alright
when when when do you is absolutely have
to get out of here so hopefully if you
can extend it a little past four but I
don't want to keep you from other things
the only thing I have to do is turn in
my top I don't know it haha this closes
that's probably five I think it's
probably 60 4 20 okay great
why should do it for my mom I'm gonna
mistake I didn't tell ya know they have
such slow internet service there's no
way to do it well I don't think maybe
it's better that you didn't yeah
probably blow their mind
so I'm going to pick back up with the
standard I we've sort of i'm not sure
when we cut out we might want to do a
little bit of beyond the standard model
again so we might have to backtrack a
little bit
whereas because the simplest question
you've gotten so far the simplest
question from the from the audience
while someone who has asked do we really
understand the current forces and sent
me a link to x x MF propulsion scom
which seems very official and promising
um there what is it Oh someone asked why
the quantum which i think is hilarious I
don't want it even sure how could you
get him through that very deep questions
to be room we understand forces yeah
yeah why the content on the ground
that's true um what else I think the
thing we'll want to address this is a
very good comment several physicists say
that it would be much more exciting if
the particle found it sir and turned out
not to be the Higgs and you know
elaborate on what they're asking why
that why that is so yeah so well I think
we'll start back up with that
okay I think we are back sorry everyone
Google is having a little bit of
technical difficulties or just trashed
their servers like no big deal um so we
are again this is the future of physics
a live chat with Janet Conrad and Chris
fig live from triple-a s in Boston I'm
with Z wait I'm a reporter with science
and we were talking before Google failed
us we were talking about what the
standard model of physics is and why we
need or want to go beyond it and so we
were saying that the the standard model
is a set of rules that that govern how
particles and how particles interact
with each other and we were talking
specifically about the Higgs boson which
was the last missing piece of the
standard model that we hadn't found
which was found last summer at CERN we
have a question from one of our viewers
Kyle several he says several physicists
say that it would be much more exciting
if the particle found at CERN turned out
not to be the Higgs please elaborate on
this it's hard to imagine it could be
any more exciting it already is but it
is certainly right that if we have
gotten a total surprise that fact would
have given us new direction and may be
closed off some some of the lines that
we're working on now well we don't know
that this is exactly the part of the
predictive of the static model we have a
lot of things to check people to know
that even though that there's not going
to turn out to be a second one we don't
know merely that it's an elementary
particle has predicted what's that
incorporating the standard model still
remotely possible that it could be a
positive structure of some some sort
otherwise this one some dynamical
principle still to believe that still
than we found it is true that if the
characteristics of it it's an unstable
neutral particle if the characteristics
up at the different patterns of decay
have been very different than what we
expected first we wonder whether it
really had to do with electronics
Wow and second it would be a sign that
there must be something else Sharon
belieber so indeed to it could have been
exciting in that direction I think it
looks ugly yeah it's a mistake to think
that just because it turned out more or
less the minimal way talked about since
nineteen sixty-seven so that that's not
a great achievement and groove
revelation the job of the experiments
after after all is to discover what's
there okay she disagrees it did not turn
the nimble way to people that it
succeeds in the sense that every year
you know if I that I was in physics
people have said oh they think he's just
around the corner it is it came out to
be much more massive than we ever
expected now we found out that that was
true indirectly right but you know uh
there was a time when people hoping this
would be one right and so you know this
I think is something where we have
progressed along and when people say
exciting or not exciting um you know
what they're saying as well there were
ways that we could predict what is matts
ended up being but we only managed to
put those words together in the last ten
years so I'm definitely a little bit of
food again what we could show that
really is funny they're very little
talks is that the object of a fight of
all of it expose on how to do i do a
lesson 83 right and that's toughest area
for the experiments me accelerates the
bill it is true that some of my
theoretical colleagues were after all an
excitable bunch we're sure that it
weighed less than 10 GB eyes in the 30gb
iron and remember that too one of the
shortcomings of the standard one is that
the standard model contains no
calculation to the luxury to calculated
predict in advance to mask the
constraints that you refer to gain from
hitting the standard model with this one
parameter at the unknown to a host the
whole universe of experimental data
miraculously because this is a construct
of human beings miraculously was
possible to do that and it was on that
basis that we were able to say
with a little footnote if the standard
models right what the things one should
weigh something of the order so I
haven't regresan both of em all and I
argue that this is a complete you know
this wasn't experimentally Griffin yeah
oh yeah we actually have a question
about you know the difference between a
theory and experiment and which one
should sort of drive physics Paul jerk
says while the standard model continues
to be solidified their seem to be more
preoccupied with mathematical wizardry
than physical phenomenon how soon before
we actually have solid contact with
experimental data that isn't adequate
adequately explained by 30 year old
theories so that's fighting words from
home so i would say that any field that
is really exciting is one where we keep
having this the switch between theory
and experiment so sometimes theory is
driving experiment and sometimes
experiment is driving here and right now
i would tell you it in my own field a
neutrino physics experiment is really
driving theory we have a lot of
observations of properties that need
didn't know we're there it just shown up
in the last 10 to 15 years we have a
whole set of what we like to call
anomalies they are results which are
tantalizing they are at a level which is
reasonably significantly usually for
three sigma it's reasonably significant
but not highly significant because we're
continuing to improve our experimental
capabilities in this area so this is a
place where experiment is really driving
theory but in a healthy field this
doesn't go on for so long theorists come
back and say oh you know we have these
different ideas when you can go and look
for how these please go so you want a
place where they play well together and
what I have to say I'll just say right
I'm an experimentalist at heart I really
like to to listen to what nature tells
me and I'm not very interested in like
all-zero some humble course the
interplay between 13 expand
it's absolutely essential to our field
in the realm of for the illyrian expose
on physics it's been acute over the last
25 to 30 years we've had ideas for what
might develop where to look numbers of
my colleagues have done quite brilliant
very innovative work in calculating
signals and backgrounds to the piece
precision so we could make sense of the
experiments the experiments contributed
in many ways by telling this don't go
there maybe you should go there and so
on so I think has been fantastically
exciting it is true when there's a hint
in your question that there are
theorists who are not closely engaged
it's easy to say well they're often stop
and when I was a when I was full of the
certainty of you thought that one but i
have to say more and more as I getting a
longer perspective on physics I realized
that people who are off doing things
that seem almost like math games may be
fine brilliant i used the wrong
phenomenon but we have a collective
memory and someday we will make use of
those things so a lot of the things that
seem arcane the Wonder wine is anybody
doing this ten fifteen twenty five years
from now there may be a little nugget
that we found in and we say these people
were onto something even if they have no
appeal maybe the same thing happens our
experiment also in the sense that there
are people out there who are developing
detectors for the wonder of the
detectors and felt and thank goodness
they're out there right because you know
these you look at what your options are
especially pick a big breakthrough like
we had a neutrino physics where suddenly
our detectors are pretty crude for what
it is that we need to do next to be able
to look out there and find people who
have been developing ideas for the sake
of developing those ideas that's an
enormous not to us I would measure also
neutrino physics would say to fit all
these new discoveries sort of it's ever
been between looks more from one species
to another in the situation theorists
had raised the possibility of many words
or we didn't know that they were really
expressed adventure
and so you know it's one thing to say
well this could happen maybe you should
look for life and so on it's very
different to have size understanding how
it's your coming out and so experiment
has told us in a number of places this
will be dream really did happen and then
it gives all of us something definite to
think about but this is a nice example I
think of the experiment chasing furies
it's an experiment because the reason
why here is put forth that neutrinos
might be able to do this one thing was
because we saw in the cork sector that
cayons a certain funk particle that we
have was doing this more thing and basic
okay well you know there's so many of
these what we call symmetries cases
where in one area something seems to
work it so we can look at another
particle and see if it works for that
too uh and so then you know we go back
to the experiments and look for the
experiment nice exam all of this another
reason you hope you're not possible
relief is that there was a rule called
black on certain fighting between over
at state a front of neutrinos forever
but we realized we had never found any
reason and so while you take it as an
experimental fact subject to appointment
it's always in the back of your mind I
don't know why this is happening and so
maybe if we find something and indeed
when the experiments between sense of it
up that's okay so rather actually a big
problem of the standard model because we
have to now put in this Katrina morphing
in it yeah that's let's talk a little
bit about neutrinos specifically because
a lot of things are getting you know a
lot of sort of things are getting thrown
around and let's let's take a step back
and talk about exactly what what these
surprises in a tree know behavior are
that you're talking about and how you
think that they are Janet I think you
you particularly can address this how
what what is what are the surprises that
neutrinos present and how can we use
those to potentially explore new physics
so so the big surprise so you train has
come in three different types and you
know it's not level of a type of
neutrino which we often call lepton is
use the lepton flavor to describe it
you can kind of think of that as a kind
of DNA sequence or something like that
for the vertical it gives you a sense of
the identity of particle and what's
really interesting is that a neutrino
can start out as one type and after some
time when you look at the neutrino you
discover it's become a different type so
it's a little like starting with a cat
and suddenly discovering with all which
is a very surprising thing to have
happen but this can happen quantum
mechanically we can try to explain how
this works in quantum mechanics and so
one we went out and we made some
observations related to neutrinos coming
from the Sun we were looking for a
particular type of neutrino from the Sun
and we didn't get the number that we
actually expected to see first the
experimental explained of theorists and
said oh you don't have to calculate
mommy neutrinos come from Sun then the
experimentalists blame the surf in the
theorists blamed extra mentalists and
said oh you don't know how to cut the
number of neutrinos in your detector
then we got together and we said maybe
something's going on with the neutrinos
and that they are more thing as they
come from the Sun and so this was our
clue this was one of our first blues
that this was actually happening and
since that time we have started to see
this all over the place we see this in
neutrinos me out here we see this in
between those from accelerators and
we're able to actually build a model
based on the standard model we can do a
small extension to the standard model
and explain a lot of the features but
there are some serious problems with
this and one of them is that we seem to
see some more thing that doesn't fit
what's going on when you only have three
nutrients and so one of the questions is
are there extra particles out there and
given the fact that we have so many
fundamental particles suggesting that
there are more particles out there isn't
such a bad thing and so so this is this
is one of the big questions that we're
pursuing at the moment along with just
trying to fit in this feature that
neutrinos into our standard model into
our set of laws race
too interesting to comment on that but
as you eventually ruin this back and
forth between theory experiment starting
with neutrinos from the Sun later if
atmospheric neutrinos interestingly
although the one phase was the notion
that between those more physical than
the Sun he was as actually not what
happens for us do not do their more heat
inside the Sun right then [ __ ] just
keep jover and so there is also subtlety
contained in the understanding but we
looked at I think the not um another
interesting aspect of neutrino physics
is that with some assumptions that we
don't yet have a test it's possibly use
cosmological observations to set bounds
on certain between our parameters such
as the number of neutrinos the studies
of the baryon acoustic oscillations the
Cosmic Microwave Background the so on
threatening to give a very strong limit
for the number of neutrino species it
might be smaller than what's necessary
to accommodate the suggestions that's
what's exciting yeah well the exciting
thing for a theory priceless to see a
contradiction ah because if you were to
demonstrate conclusively the day after
tomorrow if there are so-called sterile
neutrino species and runs of
interactions and some reputable
ownership cosmological observers come
along and say that can't be right then
something has to protect something is is
incomplete or wrong in our understanding
and from that might have took about it
but what's what it is really exciting
about this is that there's a whole set
of results is just come in which are
actually indicating to the neutrinos in
cosmology at the again to three sigma
level so very interesting but not
something which is absolutely conclusive
so and that's been fairly recent
actually in fact that the most recent
results without you have only just came
out and
so I was very excited about that and in
another I think it's going to be eight
weeks of self want with them right so
that's something for people to watch is
these new results that are kind of come
out and font compass and the number of
effective neutrinos and are there said
she would be true to the future maybe
but you only make discoveries but by
working from anomaly that so neutrino
physics is one way that some people are
hoping to go beyond the standard model
um Chris you have another way that you
are particularly excited about well
there are things that are not explained
in the standard is very compelling
evidence nothing is a significant amount
of dark matter rule is that doesn't
interact strongly would interact only
weakly could interact from
gravitationally who knows well more
likely that it has has weak interactions
we've not found what it is there are a
host of endeavors going on there are
astronomical observations using
gravitational rinsing but not only show
that it's their butts allocate we're in
space and redshift if it has been so
that's very exciting the idea if there's
something that you can't see but you can
make a map of where it is that's great
you're there are experiments to detect
our motion through the ste of dark
matter particles appealing collisions of
those particles with us that would be
terrific without a constant signal those
could show that the stuff is really the
nerd has a puzzle want of your lifetime
and then there are in direct
observations of all that people want to
do that it also give needs so that's the
violation of food opportunity particles
and finally there are the glider
experiments which are trying to actually
make things in the laboratory that would
be candidates for Doctor it RX
laboratory experiments we will never
show that the particles that could be
candidates have cosmological lifetimes
who need another bit of information to
talk together but that's an area in
which the sensitivity of the direct
detection experiments becoming quite
sense point to elevated right now and is
reaching you know the next two orders of
to sensitivity are going to be very
telling for that place about that's one
place this shows hearing nicely that you
know particle physics has really pushed
very very hard on the equipment that it
has its accelerators and its detectors
and subway and now we're getting a lot
of input from astrophysics and cosmology
because nature and do these amazing
things that we cannot necessarily do in
the lab very long lifetime experience
beautiful very high energy some things
like that we're trying a firm enough to
push the frontier of sensitivity for
those experiments again in the spirit of
testing the conservation laws that we
know a fun experience for which we don't
have any food weeds so left on flavor
violation it's suggested by the idea
that neutrinos can more from one player
to another that maybe anyone could
change into an electron given the right
tickle to it we know that in the
standard model that process happens but
it's tremendously suppressed and so we
may see nothing but there's a whole very
large window over there to protect
something it would be quite
revolutionary standard so we're trying
to push Femi lab also experiments in
elsewhere to really zero in exquisitely
rare processes those are the rare white
screens are not in much much rarer in
the standard model again to look for
kingston around the time on things that
are can't be explained great the one
theory that has come up um you hear
about a lot when people talk about
beyond the standard model physics and
that we got a question about is super
symmetry um the question that we got
from Wendell is what evidence do we have
for supersymmetry or compelling argument
that it probably this he says it seems
to me who so these matter physicists
today says it seems to me that the
arguments for it are motivated mostly by
a desire to find more particles so can
one of you explain what supersymmetry is
and why we think it might exist or why
we think it might not
exists or what that's what's a promising
is it still as promising as it once was
maybe motivated buyer so far unfulfilled
desire to find a party the sake list of
the symmetry in the state discovery but
in addition to all the kinds of
symmetries that we know about and all
the kinds of dimensions of space that is
facing time that we know about in that
dream about there is the possibility of
having quantum direct quantum dimensions
which could give us a new fight of
symmetry it's a symmetry that relates
particles with integer spin bosons as we
call them particles of half-integer spin
all criminals it's a lovely construction
I have no doubt if major that's my
opinion nature should take advantage of
this that's my predicament one of the
points that that is particularly feeling
is that if you apply supersymmetry in
just the right way you can indeed derive
white stars gravitational equations but
so it looks like a link between might be
a fundamental beautiful symmetry and a
pass to incorporate gravity with the
other interaction cephus attracted the
attention and repeat now because of some
technical properties of supersymmetry
that it minutes exact form it would make
clothes on for every fermion it would
stabilize some little problems in a
standard model and so many proponents of
supersymmetry would like to see if
manifest itself on the TV scale the same
energy skin whether exploring at the LXE
and so they explore the possibility of
the Higgs boson we found might have some
partners that would suggest that
supersymmetry there that there would be
other kinds of particles as spinless
particles that he made what marks and
things like that we've not seen any of
those so far I think it's too soon to
say that that notion of super simple
super symmetric particles on the TV
scale is ruled out if there are still
some forms to look in but certainly the
simple ones with expectations that
people have have not been fulfilled and
so I think we're some rethinking
necessary
my own view as I said prejudice not the
featured as so listen is the
supersymmetry probably got it as
manifested in nature in some way whether
it's on this TV scanner or not is it
purely experimental question and so the
nuisance fighting either four years from
now either it will have been seen the
whole set of your particles to study
stana or Raonic and see and we will have
to put it aside as an explanation for
what's happening on the TV escape in
which case we need to come up with
another explanation because it is very
strange that all of the particles that
you see all have masses within a very
specific range you can a wide range of
NASA's all the way up the gut scale and
so the fact that they're all gathered in
one area was a very interesting question
without the mechanism of supersymmetry
but explanation for this event there is
have a lot of all the times of course we
have a bunch of those right we haven't
seen any news for those either are there
any like alternatives that are emerging
to supersymmetry that you guys are
pretty girly excited about well the
general idea of dynamical symmetry
breaking what it is that the Higgs
mechanism that we talked about the
electroweak symmetry jerkiness is
modeled on a phenomenon of
superconductivity borrowed from
condensed matter physics and its bottom
good modeled in fact on a very simple
phenomenological description of
superconductivity about my scarab X the
exclusion magnetic flux but supermarket
there is in superconductivity more
detailed microscopic explanation welcome
our guinea cooking schrieffer theory in
which the magic super deducted charge
barriers and not elemental things on our
correlated pairs of electrons and so
that's got a pretty good genes as a
motivation and we've made up a group of
theories that are based on that idea the
evidence says it is rolling in from the
IHC on the higgs boson
does not if not does not encourage any
version imagine so far but they're a
bunch of ideas how did we do with X
connections and things like that and you
know why do we know there's something
there that this things like HP we get to
study in filling up their point I think
experimental felons have gotten very
deep now in the sense that we have to
figure out how we're going to take a
step beyond in understanding the
properties of the particles that we have
that at the moment and we want to keep
looking of course for new particles but
we can learn a lot about the existence
of other particles indirectly through
these high precision experiments that
Chris was mentioning earlier and so I
think that's the way that we're going to
need to go now to understand more about
what's going on it was a very
interesting synergy define euphoria
let's see we would want to be diagnostic
to figure out whether they behave in
spectrum interpretations would get to
them and one way of doing that is to
look there for their effects and very
very processes at the same time to the
extent we haven't seen anything of that
kind yet see we can use our constraints
for our processes to suggest you could
look here you children there he really
liked on the contradictions sorry at the
the fascinating thing about particle
physics over the last 20 years or a
little more is the common language that
we have them systemic model or
discussing oldest and the ability to
leave together different experiments to
the tapestry that suck talks have a
little tear of it and this is
consistently how science makes progress
right that what happens is that they'll
be dumb suddenly and then there will be
a whole tapestry that we leave following
up on those ideas and we'll find little
problems with it and when we put all of
these together suddenly we'll get the
next week and this has just happened
over and over and over again
historically so I think that you know
we're in the process at the moment
trying to understand
out of this and all of the pieces and
where they don't fit together really do
and sometimes we don't understand why
they do fit together sometimes why do
you spit together is as important to
question as why do these other things
not now we've got a couple of comments
on it from our viewers about and no
cautioning us or me has been the rest of
it you know the non physicists against
being you know getting pessimistic about
whether we've discovered any everything
or if there's anything we've discovered
the Higgs is there anything left for us
to do one of our viewers says the
history of physics is so shown us that
when we think we know everything nature
will have a humbling surprise for us
especially making Pasha absolutely
that's why I'm chocolate avec that even
happens when we don't another another
viewer says it was mentioned in eighteen
nineteen eighteen ninety that we should
close the patent office because
everything was invented right haha
that's completely true and i think you
know if you want to talk about a theory
that does a remarkable job of explaining
almost everything and yet ran into a
[ __ ] that caused a huge step forward
you can use electricity and magnetism
right there is something which was
working so beautifully and it was you
know it was working i would argue much
more beautifully than the standard long
hike and and yet you know we run into
this [ __ ] that completely takes us
forward and moves us into relativity it
allows us to can to understand the idea
of photon cement poured one weekend is
extremely important I've never been
tempted by the notion that we learned
all there is to learn maybe we looked
under only a finite number of rocks or
funny places to look there are plenty of
puzzles that we wouldn't understand
including what lies behind in structure
found I sometimes have been tempted to
make an extravagant statement though it
is a famous statement living by why
we're really in the market kelvin
faculty at 1890s about sort of welders
love no new concepts to be discovered
but more precise measurements
interestingly some of those precise
measurements lead us to do understand
that's partly do them but he made that
just after he made that the electron was
discovered x-rays were discovered it
really actually was this from so if I
thought that by making such a statement
I could precipitate flooded mood was
feminist why would he wanted to go on so
let's talk about let's go back a little
bit to this puzzle of gravity um we had
a couple weeks touched a little bit on
it before our technical difficulties
agenda was saying you know that one of
the main problems with the standard
model is that it doesn't include gravity
right and so can we talk a little bit
about some theories about what gravity
could be how we could maybe include it
in our in our future series and we have
a question about gravity from one of our
viewers Andy what kinds of experiments
could help show how gravity fits in with
the standard model force that's a really
good question and perhaps they're saying
that although the title of this chat is
the future of physics humility requires
us to say that we've been talking mostly
about the future particle filters
there's a lot of physics up here we're
not taking that all on it in the single
hour but there are numerous experiments
looking for any asians from Newton's law
these are done so sort of a meta scale
leaders say nothing was almost tabletop
experiments the things that could go to
somewhat larger distances so long so
hard there's been no evidence for
anything beyond Newton's long scale but
it's the difficulty those experiments if
you reminder of how much we've taken
think because we've given to us fugly
and how little we have explored it
experimental Italy they're 12 or 13
orders of magnitude over which we will
explore on standard normal and know that
it is where we not get that's not proof
that gravity as we understanding is
going to change that's
but it's a reminder that we were making
extrapolations so had they turned up
some interesting effect I did good
evidence for water jets two dimensions
of space-time is something like that as
people make experimental steps not
Justin are direct field related field
there are clues that we want give
supersymmetry if we have evidence would
surface in the food that pushes you in a
certain direction so it's you know it's
not to feel too much we noted in some
measurement just around the corner but
it's one many people are making sex one
of the reasons why it is so difficult to
make steps related to gravity is that
I'll make a statement and I think it
will surprise a lot of people we
listening to this gravity is very very
weak it is very weak compared to all of
the other forces involved and let me
give you a good example of this I can
take a tiny little refrigerator magnet
and I can hang a paper clip from this so
my time your refrigerator magnet can
defeat the entire Earth okay the entire
earth is pulling with its gravity on
that paper clip and my little magnet
defeats it so it's just it's very weak
and as a result it makes it very very
difficult to do test with this unless
for example you wanted to test on very
large scales um you know so that so it
or these incredible precision
experiments that that look for
deviations from Newton's laws so that is
why it's been so hard to access now on
the other hand if you're looking for
beyond the standard model physics I
claim that it is easiest to listen to
look for be honest intermountain physics
ER or listen for it is the way I like to
describe it in a place that's very quiet
so the weaker the interaction at some
level the easier it is to hear beyond
the standard model physics because it's
a quiet environment this is why I like
the weak interaction where I do my work
but certainly within gravity it's even
weaker and but have the same thing sort
of thing with new forces could show
themselves up to
the things that can happen in these high
precision experiments that are testing
Newton's laws is that you could actually
discover another force I blew that and
what's there to say that there's only
four forces you know we this is what we
found right but what is there is that in
fact some of our theories that try to go
beyond the standard model and unite the
horses of the Senate of multiple strong
interaction we like to weaken reaction
imply the existence of resources that
would make transitions between quarks
and whatnot say perhaps giving rise to
proton instability things out that we
don't yet have experimental implication
indications for those seconds but if we
should find them we've again show that
there's a bigger structure with the
snapper market isn't some of those
experiments are going on each other
victron oscillations proton decay and
other science of multiple teachers I
think we have time for one more question
because we're we're going to go a little
longer because of the interruption
earlier but I want to talk a little bit
about dark matter and dark energy where
you taught me touched on them previously
but you know dark matter we are there
are some ideas about what particles it
could be we have to prove they exist we
have to find them in space dark energy
as far as I know we don't know anything
about how close do you guys feel like
are you are these questions exciting to
you and your work and how close do you
think we are to solving this mystery let
me take over first as we said in our
department search an accelerator is a
direct detection indirect detection else
walk across to memphis tigers and so on
I think that's very close I think over
the next ten years at least along that
one blow and we drove a found candidates
to dark matter there doesn't have to be
just one it could be many eyes or we
will find that that paradigm is not
standing up now interestingly there is
an alternative to the standard
explanation the standard office is
forgotten and it comes from the one
little problem here Stone wash
quadro dynamics is a wonderful period of
launches to explain you from the proton
mass interactions of my images and so on
Janice collie Carlo jack has called it
our most perfect eerie only partly
because of that sir okay so it's really
good it has no mathematical
inconsistencies that prevent it from
being true up to really really on your
movies but there is one little ammonia
question and that is left to its own
devices and precisely because it's a
period of strong interactions it gives
rise to spontaneous moderation service
charge carried symmetry CP violation on
that requires a certain parameter be
tuned to a stupendously small we have
only one keeling theoretical idea that
we solve that it's just about new
symmetry but both years ago five in a
win and the implication of that symmetry
is that there should be a certain very
light particle of axially that would
solve the problems don't seek evaluation
but which interestingly although it's a
very light particle for you good
Nicholas bano de bistec its current
temperature universe could because it
acts coherently act as some of the Dark
Matter so it could be a different
pronunciation that would also tie into
one of our misunderstandings of the
strong interaction or dark energy my
hope what people are making observations
that will teach us more about its
characteristics really default something
like the cosmological constant and my
hope for the Higgs boson and what we
learned from that is that we may learn
lessons he erected lessons that we can
apply in thinking about the origin I
don't know that the laboratory
measurements that we can make the lead
us to understand so so I'm wearing less
agreed with what Chris is saying I think
that this is a really hot times for dark
matter experiments and what's really
great is that for a while we have
followed along a very particular type of
dark matter experiment where we were
looking for the idea of
were very heavy dark matter particles
that might run into our detector and
bump into them but we're branching out
word now because we haven't seen
anything there and we're starting to
look at different kinds of dark matter
so we're improving these axioms that
means that the big prospective talking
about we're also looking at ways that
you might actually really reduce the
dark matter so there's a whole series of
experiments and this is I'd say this is
a really flowering time or dark matter
experiment this is fun for me because a
lot of experimental developments there
are things that I can use also over in
my field the thing to realize about dark
matter is the dark founder has actually
been around as an idea for a long time
we've been wondering about dark matter
for many many years I would argue that
we really only realized that dark energy
was a possibility you know in 1998 a
little bit later than that and so that's
a very short time scale in the time
scale of science and developing ideas of
how you're going to go after something
so so we now had a lot of time to figure
out how we're really gonna go after the
star vanity question so again I mean
what that makes is an area that's very
right for us to play with right and see
where we can build so that's the kind of
thing that motivates people like me
there's one little while luckier that
I'm hopefully has much substance yet I
could be just a coincidence some of our
visionary colleagues have noticed that
the scale of the cosmological constant
and the scale of the neutrino message
the chemicals kinetic study are pretty
close to each other and so I think it's
close to each other related to each
other right for the moment just talk but
we will turn it yourself well great I
think well let's let's take just one
more quick question just please keep
your answer is very short um this is
from one of our viewers the questions
the question on everyone's mind is what
are the latest developments on a unified
theory that's the Holy Grail still
waiting for an answer do you agree and
what are the latest developments for a
unified theory which again is this idea
that we could have one equation or
one-third of equation
I would describe all the forces that we
know about including gravity all of the
particles cetera to tied up and let me
just put out i think that one of the
biggest problems with putting together a
unified theory is this problem with the
proton goes for me the fact that we
haven't seen any evidence for this is a
real issue because one of the big issues
that we have to try to tie together in
any kind of unified theory is the fact
that we have these quarks that make up
the proton and we have leptons that are
out there you know they're facing to be
completely separated from each other and
we don't know how to connect all of this
up although there's a very strange
feature about this somehow you can take
three quarks and when you put them
together you get exactly the charge of
the laptop yeah perfectly so their
universe has no overall net charge
issues associated with it so you know
something's clearly going on there and I
think it has to manifest itself
experimental II and proton decay exactly
in a scene that is really you know an
issue for these pretties unified
theories so maybe so architect the
motivation of the quality electron
charge of the proton charge very
powerful operation the thing for unified
theories of assembly contractions it is
true that the first there is written
down what good as they are or predicted
anticipated proton decay everybody
that's not been seen theorists or
infants with inventive it's easy to fix
that problem on the other thing that we
look at is that you can tell a story in
which the evolution of the three puffs
levels that have to prove it Starly can
look magnetic interactions as a function
of energy as the coupling swags change
as a function of energy are tending to
come together at some pie scale if you
do nothing they don't quite come
together if you involve invoke
supersymmetry on the screen where it's
getting a little touching they do seem
to come together and one of the
measurements that we may be able to make
that we would launch have no longer
about the strength of the swung in its
run up as a function of energy might
point us in the direction of
some who said it part of this company or
not so there we have the interesting
possibility that in the laboratory we
can give us a give ourselves a hint for
and against the motion that evolution of
the companies is changing they agree
they're looking for some sort of non
conservation either in the adjoining new
translations of would be what you need
it is however possible to make a theory
which low-energy parameters and be
predicted by the students and give only
supersymmetry there or there at the TV's
yeah we did say that we've had such a
story a lot of it is telling stories to
each other and then Testament well great
I think that's that's the wonderful look
into the next 50 years of physics know
that one hour is come to an end I think
we're all really excited to see what the
next one is going to bring thank you so
much to our guests Janet Conrad of MIT a
neutrino experimentalists Chris quigg
theorists from Fannie lab um please you
know I know chris is on twitter at chris
Quig with 2 g's do are you on twitter
Janet [ __ ] you should have been about me
on twitter at at with you underscore
wait and thank you so much for watching
we have another a google hangout
tomorrow with another live from triple-a
us hanging out about the scars of
evolution that our amazing reporter and
Gibbons is going to be moderating so
please tune in tomorrow saturday WRA
16th at three pm eastern to participate
in that discussion thanks again for
watching and have a great weekend thanks
Lizzie thank you